i do think that i am
funny because i went through so much
pain i think that humor com i don't
think i know that humor comes from pain
and i don't i think the funniest people
have been hurt the most that's my
personal opinion right you know when
people go on stage and they're so
[ __ ] funny i'm like that person has
gone through [ __ ] right i really believe
that for sure um you ever look at comics
you haven't been through anything and
you go what are you doing oh yeah i'm
like you're too okay yeah you're like
why are you doing this there's so many
comics who are just clever i never laugh
at clever comedy no and i have people do
like they'll do well on stage louis said
something great once it's like i forget
did louis say it i forget who said i
think it was louis where it was like
it's comedy for people who went to
vassar yeah yeah yeah it was some it
might not have been louis but somebody
it was like that type of
where it's like it's very it's very well
thought out
yeah i've never laughed at seinfeld now
he's a great writer i've never once
laughed at anything here's the most
brilliant thing because he's technically
one of the most brilliant comics i'm i'm
sure he loves him he'd love me
uh that's sarcastic but
um
what the one time i really laughed at
him is he did a speech for the clio
advertising awards where he goes
uh it was the funniest thing that i've
ever seen him do because it was the most
real bet ben can get it up
this is him being the most real i've
ever hold on one second this is him
being the most real
i've ever seen it is my one of my
favorite things i've ever seen a comic
do because the thing with him is
some of his jokes are so technically
brilliant they're brilliant
brilliant writers but there there is
sort of you feel like you you feel like
you don't know him and that's my thing
that's what i'm saying i i this is just
my personal opinion but here if you
watch this this to me
is one of the best things because now i
do kind of feel like i know him if you
watch this right
i am excited to win this this
this is the award they give you when
they don't think you can actually win
one
but they think you've done a pretty good
job and seem to have been around for
quite some time
and that's how i got it
uh i would like to thank ogilvy and
maythere in american express for getting
me into this business
that was the first time i i did it i
would like to thank my manager george
shapiro
my incredible wife jessica
and amarati for keeping me going
i love advertising
because i love lying
in advertising everything is the way
you wish it was i don't care
that it won't be like that when i
actually get the product being
advertised because
in between seeing the commercial and
owning the thing
i'm happy
and that's all i want
tell me how great the thing is going to
be i love it i don't need to be happy
all the time
i just want to enjoy the commercial
i want to get the thing we know the
product is going to stink we know that
because we live in the world and we know
that everything stinks
we all believe hey maybe this one won't
stink
we are a hopeful species
stupid but hopeful
but we're happy in that moment between
the commercial and the purchase and i
think spending your life trying to dupe
innocent people
out of hard-won earnings to buy useless
low-quality misrepresented items and
services is an excellent use of your
energy
that's different than what he does
that's right this is why i love it here
keep watching this is great
because a brief moment of happiness is
pretty good
i also think that just focusing on
making money and buying stupid things is
a good way of life
i believe materialism gets a bad rap
it's not about the amount of money
nothing's better than a bic pen
a vw beetle or a pair of regular levi's
if your things don't make you happy
you're not getting the right things
this will all be in my new book soulful
materialism which is in the planning
stages
at this moment
i have always wanted a clio
i don't know much about it
but i know it's a good award
because in 1991 they screwed up this
whole presentation
and there were a bunch of awards left
over and all of these ad people here
climbed up onto the stage and tried to
grab them
so to me that says this means something
that really happened and it's my
all-time favorite award show occurrence
because it was so honest
people just said i want a damn clio and
they went for it
and that is why i am happy right now
i got this i didn't really win it but i
got it
and tomorrow i don't know where this is
gonna be it'll be somewhere
eventually i'll be dead someone will
just take it or sell it or throw it out
and that's fine i'm happy now
the same way those executives were in
1991 when they ran onto this stage and
grabbed trophies that weren't theirs
[Applause]
but it trumped up their phony careers in
meaningless lives
so thank you all i mean it's like so
that
i saw that i was like this is like
this moment it's real yeah it's totally
real and dark and dark but he's not
i've watched him a million times it's
not his usual thing it's safe and it's
not
real a lot it's just yeah it's a
different thing yeah it's a different
thing what do you think like is
happening
you know with comedy right now where you
have a lot of comics who are cool
and you have a lot of people that seem
like
they are on stage to make a point
um
and
they feel like they're a gay comic
or they're a comic of color or they're a
comic or they're a trans comic it
doesn't feel like the community of
comics feels more divided and splintered
now than it's kind of ever been
it feels like the identity of comic
to me is such a powerful strong identity
it should unite all these different
groups of people
under that umbrella it doesn't seem to
anymore seems to be weirdly balkanized
where everybody's kind of doing their
own thing it is yeah it is divided
um
a lot of comics have gone
at each other which i am not used to it
was very united for my entire career
yeah and now um people are incredibly
judgmental of each other i i personally
have never judged comics for what they
do so it's very odd for me to see
comics going at each other yeah
i i could hate someone's act
be disgusted by it um
hear what they have to say and want to
vomit and want them to die
but i still believe they have the right
to say it
so uh yeah and i just you know i i laugh
at what's funny
and i just think the funniest people
should get hired for work that's right
so it's just i don't know what's going
on good luck with that point i know
i just keep doing what i do and saying
what i say and i don't let anyone
silence me